something is coming I can feel it we've
been working on the film for nearly
three and a half years now it's pretty
amazing to see something that you've
been working on such a long time on a
screen of that size and in that level of
fidelity and to actually be able to see
the level of detail that's one of the
things that you get with IMAX that you
may not necessarily see on any other
screen we fight together or we die
together I think one of the benefits
being able to see that much detail is
that you really get that sense of
reality to it with a fantasy film like
this where you really are trying to get
the audience to take that leap of
imagination the more you can do the more
detail you can you can give a film I
think the more likely they are to just
buy into it and feel like their existing
in this environment along with our
heroes dark forces are upon us that imax
sound system is phenomenal it's like it
brings you into the environment that the
film takes place in I think anything
that you could do like that to just help
the audience take that one extra step
into the reality you're trying to create
is always worth the extra effort
Warcraft is this huge fantastical world
of dramatic visuals and creatures any
film where you're trying to create
worlds and bring the audience along for
the ride whether it's science fiction or
fantasy really lends itself to imax our
world is dying there is nothing to go
back to
Warcraft centers around these two
separate worlds towards the beginning of
the film the voyage from one to the
other has this sort of surreal quality
to it and it's quite a dramatic moment
in the movie and I think seeing that on
the big I max screen is pretty
spectacular this war will destroy us all
this is my third movie moon my first
movie was just this little british
independent film and source code was a
good step forward but you always kind of
feel like when you finally make a film
that's on imax you're working in the big
ten together we once done the tribes was
one of those seminal moments where you
kind of feel like okay I'm making big
movies now literally
you